lookouts because bright bold colors are
all around us
yes June is Pride Month and we've been
seeing all the colors of the rainbow as
the stars have been stepping out to
celebrate LGBTQ pride with its roots and
the pride flag dating back to 1978
there's no doubt that the rainbow motif
has become a true fashion statement
during Pride and with royal pride taking
place in New York City this weekend
we're taking a closer look at which
celebrities have been showing their
pride by rocking the rainbow last
weekend approximately 1 million people
gathered in Toronto for the annual pride
parade for Canadian pop sensation carly
rae jepsen gave a surprise performance
for fans
[Music]
there you are with carly's Stephen at
Toronto pride she looked amazing she
wore this great Cheryl purple top she
had these rainbow pants and what did you
think of the look I mean she stepped off
the bus and I was just like is there a
better look for pride she looked
incredible and she is such a sweetheart
I had a chance to actually catch up with
Carly right backstage before she hit the
stage to perform and I had a bit of a
moment because I am such a fan what do
you love about playing Pride festivals
it's just the most joyful experience
that I think I've ever had ever if you
haven't come to a pride thing you really
have them experience what it is to truly
celebrate now Taylor Swift is one star
whose new rainbow filled aesthetic I
think is very fitting for private the
star sported a tie-dye and fringe denim
jacket and matching bodysuit at the twin
MT and I Heart Radio Wango Tango concert
what do you think this looks even I
think she looked amazing she had like
the really cool fringe going on it was
very playful very chthonic it was very
fitting for her new album as well yeah I
think so too I mean you know Taylor went
a little dark with her reputation album
so it's really nice to see Taylor coming
back and with the bright colors and
she's really championing this new sense
of pride as we've seen in her latest
music video for you need to calm down
I just loved that she's been using her
voice a lot more lately for what she
believes in which is the LGBTQ community
and you know at the end of that video
she's urging people to support the
Equality Act and I think that's
incredible definitely I think she's even
voice I think Oh which is really amazing
I mean she's one of the biggest pop
stars in the world if not the biggest
pop star in the world so I think her you
know moving forward and discussing the
LGBTQ community and human rights is just
such a great thing okay what we can't
talk about pride fashion without
discussing the gorgeous Cara Delevingne
stepping out the 20 and Met Gala which
follow the theme camp notes on fashion
be modeled on this amazing sheer rainbow
to your ensemble but the playful
headpiece of bedazzled kid I mean this
is camp when I saw her step out on the
Met Gala red carpet in this I'm like
this is perfect a lot of people chose to
kind of not go as outrageous as Cara did
and I think she just killed this look
it's incredible when she's on the red
carpet she did say in her interview you
know camp to me is outrageous and I
think she always takes that stuff with
her fashion and this was a really the
perfect time her to shine yeah she's
gorgeous and I love that she recently
made her relationship public with
actress Ashley Benson and I just love
that yeah
they are the cutest couple ever and is
there a better month to celebrate love
than Pride Month I don't think so
and one of my favorite stars who has
mastered rocking the rainbow is Liz
[Music]
the singer everyone just can't get
enough of was photographed by her makeup
artist wearing this killer rainbow
makeup for indie pride and I really love
that Liz oh she uses her fashion for
self-expression I think she you know
it's really at the forefront when it
comes to just doing your thing Eddie to
Canada's Roz West and actually spoke
with Liz Oh about being a role model you
know I'm a grown-ass woman
and I know who I want to be and I know
at least who I think I am right now and
I think that because I want to be a good
person I don't mind having the title
role model or that flag yeah
given for me to represent people I just
love Liz oh I love everything she
represents she is such a strong voice
for the LGBTQ community and I love her
message of body positivity who are some
of your favorite celebrities rocking the
rainbow this month let us know your
thoughts in the comments below